después de 20 años de guerra que se
cumplen precisamente el 11 de septiembre
en algunos días tras los atentados del
9/11 del 2001 pues yo vayan dijo en su
discurso que hay puntos que aprender
primero dijo que eeuu tiene que tener
metas claras y alcanzables en las
próximas participaciones bélicas
participaciones militares que haga a
futuro y segundo dijo que además eeuu
tiene que preguntarse muy bien cuál es
el interés de eeuu en participar en
estas guerras en varias guerras que ya
se mencionaban eeuu sigue participando
en ellas por ejemplo la participación
militar que tiene eeuu en yemen en
somalia en irak todavía donde lleva
también decenas ya de años y entonces
pues lo que muchos analistas de
seguridad que conozca hemos hablado acá
en washington nos han dicho que pues
además las guerras ya empiezan a cambiar
ya no es ya no hay que enviar tantos
soldados en terreno y eeuu ya dado
cuenta de eso
recientes intervenciones militares lo
que dicen analistas de seguridad es que
lo que hay que aprender también después
de organizar es que las guerras se
luchen de una forma diferente se luchan
con mucha tecnología recordemos que
osama bin laden asesinado en el 2011 fue
asesinado con un dron entonces esta
tecnología de drones militares esa
tecnología aérea no piloteada es una
tecnología que eeuu pues se ha
perfeccionado en los últimos años y es
la que quiere usar de cara a las
próximas intervenciones militares de
eeuu como lo dicen algunos analistas acá
y también pues en la presencia y la
importancia de ejércitos privados de
compañías de seguridad privadas que el
pentágono sigue contratando no solamente
en afganistán en irak sino en muchos
otros países así que definitivamente
estos tres puntos son importantes lo
mencionó el presidente yo bailé en su
discurso y analistas de seguridad
concuerdan con él a caguas gritó a él
cuáles serían las preocupaciones
principales respecto de lo que viene de
ahora más me refiero tanto afganistán
como para eeuu y contando también que
dicen al respecto los republicanos sobre
estos réditos
claro y es que en la agenda nacional
está el tema migratorio bastante
candente bastante es muy principal en la
agenda y en el día a día de eeuu así que
lo que muchos temen sobre todo los
republicanos es el impacto migratorio
que tenga la cantidad de afganos que van
a llegar a eeuu después de que pasen por
todo el visto bueno de seguridad
recordemos que la mayoría de los afganos
que salieron del aeropuerto de kabul en
los últimos días no fueron directamente
no vinieron directamente a eeuu que sino
que terminaron en países terceros donde
haya en esos países se les va a ser un
chequeo de seguridad para es bastante
exhaustivo como lo dijo el presidente yo
vayan antes de que puedan entrar a suelo
estadounidense precisamente para evitar
cualquier
potencial ataque terrorista eso es una
cosa entonces que le preocupa mucho a
los estadounidenses no solamente ese a
potencial o ese riesgo terrorista que
deriva de esa migración de afganos sino
la cantidad de afganos recordemos que
fueron 100.000 afganos lo que en los
últimos días según lo valen fueron oa
los de afganistán y muchos más que
después de la resolución de la onu van a
tratar de entrar a eeuu así que pues ya
en medios conservadores se conversa y se
habla y se expone ese ese temor ese
miedo a esa ola migratoria afgana además
pues lo que dicen de varios republicanos
es bueno qué va a pasar en afganistán de
ahora en adelante si la misión inicial
fue irak alistan precisamente para
acabar con ese refugio de terroristas de
al-qaeda y el talibán que desde allá
operaban pues qué va a pasar ahora que
el talibán vuelve a tomar control de el
país va a ser nuevamente aprendiz tan un
refugio de terroristas que va a ser eeuu
al respecto se lucharon 20 años en ese
país para que nuevamente afganistán sea
un refugio de terroristas son preguntas
que se formulan sobre todo los
republicanos y demócratas también acá en
eeuu ahora que te vale hay un tema que
deja algunas dudas y principalmente es
la siguiente que dejó de eeuu en manos
del grupo talibán
claro sobre el tema hay mucha
especulación sobre todo el arsenal
militar que deja a eeuu el arsenal
militar que dada la rapidez en la que el
talibán se toma control de la capital y
pues de los puntos militares
estadounidenses pues obviamente quedó
mucho arsenal en manos de el talibán
ayer el pentágono cuando anunciaba
definitivamente la retirada del último
soldado que evacua agua del aeropuerto
de kabul decían que pues habían austro
auto destruido el arsenal que quedaba en
el aeropuerto de kabul y mencionaba en
cifras como 73 aeronaves mencionaban
también 23 hammers y 70 aproximadamente
vehículos anti explosivos que habían
destruido desmilitarizado los militares
estadounidenses antes de salir del
aeropuerto de kabul sin embargo pues hay
varias hay mucha especulación al
respecto y hay unas cifras que son muy
llamativas que dan varias fuentes por
ejemplo que en afganistán después de 20
años quedan cerca de 20.000 hammers
estas camionetas de guerra que quedan
de 42 mil carros y cerca de 360 mil
rifles de asaltos además de
634 tanques de guerra una cifra bastante
alta un arsenal muy grande que ya
quisieran varios países tener